[Music]
like a lot of you I'm on Facebook as
well and and just like everyone else in
this room was on Facebook every now and
then when I have a little bit of extra
time I like to you know check out the
updates and posts that are constantly
flooding in and it occurred to me we
have a little bit of time before Kevin
Nealon comes out me get this show going
so I'd like to take a moment right now
if it's okay with you guys to check in
on my Facebook feed is that okay sure
whatever it's your show my show all
right let's check it out let's pretend
this is plugged in and here we go here's
my here's my Facebook page or Facebook
there it is and pretty sure I have some
new notifications let's check it out
honey boo boo has invited you to the
event first appearance at juvenile court
2017 Tom Cruise has invited you to the
event normal cocktail party that is not
a wife audition I'll be good Nicolas
Cage invited you to the event selling
stolen copper pipes for money
[Applause]
so Wester stallone invited you to join
Mugler
all right let's let's see what's in my
newsfeed here okay Lickety guy fieri
updated his location to sour cream
mountain in douche burg tennessee nice
Mitt Romney created a new photo album
fun with the door but see what's next
Gary Busey's in a relationship with a
maple pop that's nice I'm so happy
they'll make it great Khloe Kardashian
changed her profile pic Lindsay Lohan
has posted her photo album deployed
airbags Kanye West
let's see Kanye West likes Kanye West
let's check out check out status check
out my newest album comment from Kanye I
love it war please response from Kanye
on it bro
keep it real comment from Kanye love you
and look comment is liked by 15 Kanye
West it's good to know interesting oh
this Chris Christie has posted a YouTube
video the love of my life let's check
that out
[Music]
[Applause]
yo I love him terrible terrible
impression of Chris we're doing good and
Andy look here on Facebook page there's
Andy has Andy has one friend
I have a lot of international fans
alright ladies and gentlemen I'm glad
thank you so much your way around a
computer computer I can't even open this
thing you will slammed it shut yeah oh
it's like busted now
oh is that even a real computer and it
is cuz we just looked at my Facebook
page
[Applause]